[Music]
[Applause]
that is always this frontman Liam
Gallagher performing a last night in
Manchester where he paid tribute to the
22 victims who lost their lives in the
terror attack and we have new details
about this Sunday's benefit concert
their plans are in full swing as ariana
grande returns for the first time since
this tragedy with an all-star lineup and
Friends benefit performer Justin Bieber
was asked about it yesterday in New York
according to her promoter the concept
for the one love Manchester show came
from ariana grande herself
it really was Ariana's idea even though
she was traumatized by these events that
she wanted to speak and sing for the
victims to raise money and to make a
statement
Grande and Bieber's manager Scooter
Braun booked all the artists including
Katy Perry Miley Cyrus Pharrell uh sure
the Black Eyed Peas
and Coldplay
[Applause]
it all happened very quickly we're
talking about within like 72 hours of
the tragedy in Manchester this is a
massive production this Manchester
School Choir will also perform during
the show which will air live on the BBC
and we should see a few special guests
according to the promoters there would
be some big names that haven't been
announced yet
anyone with passes from last week's
Arianna show was entitled to claim their
free tickets today
like this young lady whom we interviewed
right after the attack we need to get
out Nick Heywood and his daughter
Caitlin told et today they're planning
to go to Sunday's concert tickets for
everyone else go on sale tomorrow and
one thing is for certain security at the
65,000 seat venue will be paramount
concert goers are being asked not to
bring bags with them there's definitely
going to be double the security presence
that is normally anticipated at a
concert of this size the most important
thing it should be an uplifting
[Music]
you